this is very very new very very new
research is what we're referring to as
existential agency
and it relates to purpose but i i think
it's different in an important way so
purpose you could say is
i've been given a purpose right like
this is you know you can imagine purpose
outside of your own decision-making
right you could say i'm you know my
purpose in this world is to do x
some people would say no i create my own
purpose
but that's not inherent in the concept
of purpose because you can have
goal-driven behavior that you feel like
you were you were assigned like you
could say my purpose well like you said
a minute ago my purpose is to reproduce
right
um
existential agency is
you know we define it as people's belief
in their own ability to
to guide the meaning in their life to
have a meaningful life so you could say
my life is meaningful
because i have this religious belief
that you know that says all you know all
life is meaningful and i've been given
this purpose
but within that you need some kind of
drought like you need to feel like you
have the ability to take action and to
do things not just be passively pushed
around
and to say well i guess this is my
meaning i guess it's not my meaning so
there seems to be this this more
self-regulatory dimension of meaning and
that's what we call existential
agency but it is connected to purpose
and people who you know like i said this
is very very early work
but it seems like people who have a
strong sense of existential agency
even if you
control for how you know how meaningful
they see their lives it's the people who
have a really strong sense of agency
that are the most motivated they're the
most driven they're the most resilient
and they're the most entrepreneurial you
know so they're the most willing to take
risks and a lot of it has to do with the
fact that they see themselves as
responsible
for their own meaning right they feel
like when life feels meaningless they
can change it
they can do something about it as
opposed to people that you know maybe
are just more like well
i guess it just wasn't meant to be and
i'm not you know
i can't do anything about this or my
meaning is really contingent on these
other external forces
and so i think that that's and i think
that's a part of the reason i wanted to
to really start to figure that angle out
was because i feel like we increasingly
are living in a society at least here in
the
in in the us and i think this is the
case more broadly in the western world
where people are acting like you're not
in control of anything
right there's all this you know there's
all these concerns about like systemic
um
oppression and things like that and you
know this isn't to take away from real
structural challenges that people
face
but the point being is
if we're only talking about those things
that are
we think of as outside of people's
controls we're neglecting the fact that
humans have all this cognitive
horsepower up here
right regardless of what situation you
were born into in life and again clearly
there are privileges and advantages and
differences between people um
but regardless of that there's something
going on within the within humans that
gives us a great deal of cognitive
freedom if we choose to act on it right
um so i could get up tomorrow and say
you know i've been kind of lazy every
day and but this is going to be the day
that i you know i get my act together
and people do this all the time
you know people
set goals all the people change their
life for all the things we hear about
like barriers to things people all the
time absolutely
take action based on goals that they set
and priorities that they make
in order to take control over their
lives so i'm really interested in that a
genetic component of meaning
well think about why anyone ever gets
seduced or finds it really sort of
emotionally fulfilling to see those
transformation photos of some guy ethan
suplee one of my buddies the guy that
was in remember the titans and
donnie darko a bunch a bunch of films
and um
he lost like
350 pounds like he lost
two humans off of himself
and
the reason that people love that story
is that you see someone that you thought
was going down a particular path that
had a
meta narrative that they were attached
to and they were on the rails but
through force of will and effort they've
managed to
change the cart onto a different set of
railway tracks and they've done that
through their own agency so i think that
people intuitively are aware of this
it's
i think you're correct to say that the
victimhood mentality that we're seeing
at the moment um
completely outsources existential agency
and
if
man can make a heaven of hell and a hell
of heaven
then your ability to interpret how the
world is talking to you and how you are
experiencing it is more than 50 of the
battle
you know you have people that are in
like terrible terrible situations
who are able to be
relatively fulfilled and people that
seemingly have everything lottery
winners that kill themselves so right
you know your material situation is an
influence but it's not a determinant you
know you would say maybe it predisposes
but it doesn't predetermine so
yeah i think that framing things in that
way
and
allowing people to understand and
encouraging them toward look take
advantage take control of the
of the direction that your life's going
in i think that's a smart area of
research
yeah yeah thanks no and you you summed
it up perfectly i mean and it doesn't
even have to be because people tend to
think of your example's a good one a
dramatic one but even little even little
things so
you know people do
you know like you'll see research on
like even just increasing the amount you
walk
every day so you know even people who
aren't like i'm going to make some
gigantic transfer
transformation
but it's a choice just to say you know
what i'm going to take the stairs
instead of the
the elevator or i guess you would say
the lift right
like i'm going to i lived in the uk for
two years
i think i remember the word still um
but there's lots of little things that
people do
every day and even if
even if there are you know because again
you know and you made this point and
it's true like even even if you start
out with certain
vulnerabilities so let's say let you to
use an example think about like a
genetic predisposition towards
alcoholism
right
some people
just for whatever reason
um can't handle drinking
a lot of us can a lot of us have no
problems just saying you know like i
drink you know sometimes a lot sometimes
hardly at all and i can turn it on and
off it will it's no big deal
other people they just they can't crack
the bottle they really can't
but
what so so one so the victimhood
narrative as you described it which you
see a lot is
well alcohol abuse isn't really a choice
because it's a genetic disposition
and it's a disease and it's you know
um but
and so what's funny is the more we learn
scientifically about that the more
people intuitively seem to think that
well you have no control over it
but another way to look at it from an
agency point of view is thanks to our
scientific understanding of genetic
vulnerabilities you've just armed
somebody with information so now they
can say you know what i know i'm the
type of person
that can't be at the pub
that can't have alcohol in the house
and those are choices to set up your
life based on information that you now
have and so yeah and it seems so obvious
but just that simple difference of
looking at it from oh this is a genetic
predisposition i'm hopeless
to know learning learning about genetics
actually gives me information
um about my personality
about my vulnerabilities things you know
things that tempt me things that bring
out the worst than me
things that things that motivate me what
is it that inspires me to be at my best
like so the more you can learn about
these things scientifically those aren't
like determinants that that doesn't mean
like
you know your life is just being you're
just being pushed around by these by
these external causes they're
information that can help you make
choices
to you know to live a better a better
life so i actually think that as as we
learn more and more about
you know you know you know the science
of the brain um that doesn't mean we're
less in control that's giving us more
information about how to how to regulate
our own behavior but my feeling is
that's kind of a minority position in
the modern day
scholar you know western scholarship
instead people just seem to think well
here's another excuse here's another
reason why you're not it's not your
fault
um i'm like well no here's more
information that that arms you with with
the ability
um to make better choices thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you